[Musica]
troppo gentili siamo in piena era
digitale
e quindi non possiamo non comunicare
l'uso pervasivo delle tecnologie ha
cambiato le nostre vite lo sappiamo
abbiamo innescato processi di
trasformazione delle nostre società
non possiamo più vivere senza il nostro
smartphone e lo so benissimo che ce
l'avete tutti in tasca c'è anche chi lo
tiene acceso e si vede quella lucina blu
magari avete messo la vibrazione la
suoneria disattivata
ma io lo so che ve lo portate anche in
bagno chi di voi porta il telefonino in
bagno abbi il coraggio di alzare la mano
fatemi vedere
ecco io non lo voglio sapere che cosa ci
fate in bagno col telefonino però quanto
era bello un giornale di carta fare un
cruciverba leggere un fumetto lo so che
per i nativi digitali è una roba troppo
vintage old style
e lo so anche che si fanno grandi risate
guardando i loro nonni che stanno interi
pomeriggi a cercare di capire come si fa
a rispondere a una videochiamata dei
parenti lo so
però oggi voglio spezzare una lancia
proprio a loro favore ma anche alla mia
generazione e quindi vi chiedo di fare
un esperimento
modena
di digital detox e cioè
disarmiamo ci
proviamo a spegnere adesso il nostro
telefono per 10 minuti spegnerlo proprio
viviamo questa gioia di connetterci
esclusivamente con la nostra mente
unplugged con il nostro cuore con il
nostro stomaco ce la potete fare sì o no
dieci minuti della vostra vita non vi ho
sentito
ok allora avete spento siamo pronti
possiamo iniziare
è insomma si ci vuole il tempo però
credetemi io non sono contro la
tecnologia non dico queste cose perché
voglio essere assolutamente
anacronistico no
ma sono qui per dirvi che il corpo è
tornato fondamentale centrale nelle
nostre relazioni proprio in questo
momento proprio dopo tutto quello che
abbiamo vissuto
pensate a quello che è successo con la
pandemia è successo di tutto
abbiamo dovuto fare il distanziamento
sociale
non potevamo abbracciarci baciarci cose
che facevamo naturalmente abbiamo
indossato le mascherine ce l'abbiamo
anche oggi e queste mascherine coprono
il nostro sorriso che uno dei sistemi
più
meravigliosi per connettersi con gli
altri non ci riconosciamo quante volte
vi salutano ma che chi è il successo ne
sono sicuro perché noi percepiamo
l'altro grazie al corpo che abbiamo
grazie ai nostri sensi il nostro corpo
ci serve per aiutare la mente ad entrare
in relazione col resto del mondo per
entrare in risonanza con gli altri e poi
vogliamo parlare dello smart working di
tutte le piattaforme digitali che
abbiamo dovuto imparare per comunicare e
fare le nostre riunioni
quasi
disumanizzate in un certo senso lo so il
senso di frustrazione certe volte anche
chissà se se riuscirò a fare quello che
ho sempre fatto su una piattaforma non
lo so è stato difficile però per carità
ci sono stati anche dei vantaggi
bellissimi che meraviglia e vestirsi
solo a metà
lavorare in ciabatte
andare in ufficio da una stanza
all'altra del nostro appartamento e si
risparmiano soldi tempo da è una figata
però è anche vero che le telecamere sono
entrati dentro la nostra casa e hanno
cambiato il concetto di vita privata sì
perché siamo dovuti diventare tutti i
registi attori scegliere la giusta
locale
con la giusta illuminazione e che non ci
siano rumori se non facciamo brutta
figura e vogliamo parlare dei microfoni
che non funzionano della connessione che
salta è diventato un teatro dell'assurdo
e lo so
cari amici che anche voi almeno una
volta avete visto qualcuno che era
convinto di aver disattivato la
telecamera durante una riunione
e si è mostrato in mutande davanti a
tutti è successo siano
ora voglio dire per carità il digitale
ci serve molto utile fa delle cose
fantastiche però è anche vero che ha
degli effetti sulla nostra
sul nostro umore sulle nostre emozioni
sul nostro modo di essere
ci ha cambiato anche il modo di
concentrarci facciamo fatica a fare
quello che facevamo una volta cioè il
digitale non può sostituire quello che
noi animali sociali siamo in grado di
fare in presenza entrare in connessione
in empatia gli sguardi i silenzi
parlanti
forse avrete sentito parlare anche
dell'aumento re della crisi di astinenza
da smartphone avete mai sentito
pensiamo che forse una cosa che tocca
soltanto i giovani ma non è così perché
mi piacerebbe tanto mostrarvi in moviola
quella volta in cui avete dimenticato il
vostro telefono da qualche parte come il
vostro corpo ha reagito
siamo impazziti in quel momento e
pensate che legame abbiamo quindi col
digitale forse dobbiamo ricordarci che
noi per percepire il mondo abbiamo
bisogno del nostro corpo per immaginare
abbiamo bisogno del corpo per comunicare
per avere una mente abbiamo bisogno del
nostro corpo e quindi se noi frapponiamo
uno schermo tra un essere umano è un
altro che cosa accade quello che
percepivamo con i sensi è diverso e
quindi diventa un altro modo di
concepire l'altro sta cambiando si sta
trasformando il modo di comunicare
dobbiamo essere preparati
ovviamente a gestire tutto questo e come
si fa si fa pensando a una umanizzazione
delle tecnologie perché al momento in
cui si lavora per dare più umanità e
robot io ho cercato di fare solo una
cosa in questi anni
pensare alla nostra relazione umana e
concentrarmi sui bambini i ragazzi che
sono al centro del processo educativo
sono il nostro futuro e quindi per farlo
voi direte ma tu che centri in tutto
questo perché ci parli di questo perché
io come autore e regista performer ho
avuto la fortuna enorme di incontrare
una comunità fluida di persone
autentiche che hanno deciso di fare
scienza servizievole e cioè di veicolare
messaggi importanti alla gente e per
farlo mi hanno visto sul palco hanno
detto ma sai che tu col tuo modo di
comunicare con la tua voce del corpo
potresti aiutare tanti bambini tanti
ragazzi tanti educatori genitori e come
portando in scena pillole di scienza
sì mi hanno fatto diventare un per
formatore
travaso concetti molto complessi dal
mondo della scienza in modo chiaro e
semplice per educatori e ragazzi bambini
lo faccio con gli spettacoli con i corsi
di formazione
credete che sia poco
non è così
perché noi siamo un sistema vivente
pensate quando siete davanti uno
spettacolo
quella magia che si crea con l'attore e
il performer che si sintonizza con le
persone
che cos'è quella cosa lì la
professoressa daniela lucangeli
psicologa dello sviluppo dell'università
di padova nonché grande esperta di
psicologia dell'apprendimento mi ha
raccontato una cosa che voglio
trasferirvi oggi il miracolo della
lacrima e cioè che la composizione
chimica della lacrima tiene impressa
l'emozione che abbiamo provato quindi
una lacrima di dolore è diversa da una
lacrima di gioia
pensate che meraviglia quindi magari
davanti a un mio spettacolo se vi
emozionatevi viene da piangere
analizzando la vostra lacrima troveremo
l'emozione che io vi ho trasmesso per
empatia
ma che estero per fantastico e
meraviglioso no
modena ci sei
è qualcosa di straordinario no siamo
tutti connessi e questo è un
palcoscenico la nostra vita è un teatro
voi siete sicuri di essere in grado di
entrare in scena ogni giorno in tutto
quello che fate sì o no
ci siete in scena si o no
ne siete proprio sicuri e allora
facciamo un esperimento
adesso vi chiedo di fare una cosa che
non facciamo quasi mai di esprimere la
nostra gioia più totale ma esprimerlo
con che cosa con la voce con il corpo
potete fare tutto quello che vi pare
alzarvi impieri gridare fate quello che
vi pare per esprimere una gioia come
quando segna la vostra squadra del cuore
come quando avete una grande
soddisfazione professionale
una gioia nella vita
siete pronti
al mio tre
io sentirò la potenza della gioia di
modena
12 luci
luci sul pubblico per favore grazie
grazie
[Applauso]
allora forse non ci siamo capiti
ci riproviamo
io sto parlando della gioia nel cuore
quella potente quella libera quella che
ti fa fare qualunque cosa quando siete
in gioia felicità profonda
anche questa è gioia e ridiamo
allora ci riproviamo io sono sicuro che
possiamo fare di meglio con tutto il
vostro corpo potete anche alzarmi in
piedi pensate un po
e allora ci siamo
e 3
esatto allora vedete che siamo connessi
io tu noi le nostre cellule sono
connesse siamo una comunità fluida siamo
persone che hanno bisogno di essere
connesse in tutto e per tutto e farlo
con la gioia è una sensazione
straordinaria
ora
lo so che vi ho fatto spegnere il
telefono e alcuni di voi mi odieranno
però adesso forse è arrivato il momento
di riaccenderlo perché la tecnologia non
è il nostro nemico no è il nostro
alleato noi dobbiamo usarlo in modo
intelligente e allora riaccendiamo il
telefonino e adesso per favore tutti
insieme riaccendete lo è se quello che
vi ho detto fino adesso
quello che vi ho comunicato stasera con
tutto il mio corpo e con tutto il mio
sudore
sono anche i gradi che ci sono
potete filmare fotografare quest'ultima
frase che vorrei rimanesse impressa
nelle vostre vite e condividetelo anche
sui social se volete tanto siete
registrati lo sappiamo lo ritrovarvi è
un mondo digitale giusto
e allora
riappropriamoci della nostra
comunicazione autentica e diamo voce al
nostro corpo
per continuare ad essere umani grazie
[Applauso]